[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEY WONG: Welcome to "Apigee
Up Close" webcast series.
Today, we'll be
discussing a topic
that is very popular today.
And we'll have an
opportunity to do a Q&A
at the end of the webcast.
So let me introduce myself.
My name's Joey Wong.
I'm the customer engineer
for Apigee, which
is a part of Google Cloud.
And with me I have--
SARTHAK GANGULY: I am Sarthak.
I'm a partner engineer
for Google Cloud Platform.
And interestingly, I was part
of Apigee until last year.
So I have seen both
sides of the world.
And we are joining in from not
sunny but cold in New York.
JOEY WONG: It is
certainly getting colder.
So today, we'll actually be
discussing a couple of items.
And really it's about how
organizations are actually
embarking on a journey and
transition from a traditionally
on-premise to a hybrid
IT architecture and some
of those challenges that are
faced in that journey itself.
We'll also present how
Apigee can help de-risk,
in some cases accelerate
application modernization
and migration by introducing an
API management layer to broker
transactions between legacy
back-end systems and Cloud
Services.
So join us as we share
how we can help you
make that move to the cloud.
So before we get down
into the details itself,
interestingly
enough, Google itself
conducts a survey
with our customers
and our customers' CIOs.
Some of the biggest
questions are,
are they currently using
a multi-cloud strategy?
And based on our
survey, the response
has been very eye-opening.
Based on the survey
itself, 96% of the CIOs
and the customers that
we actually talk to today
have actually either deployed
or are working on deploying
or are thinking seriously
about a multi-cloud strategy.
And the reasons for this are a
number of key points, really.
It's really about
empowering the organization
to mix and match
solutions and to be
able to leverage
innovative technologies
from the different cloud
providers themselves.
Every single one
of our customers
have some unique
requirements, which
they need to then tailor
their solutions based
on those requirements.
And additionally, it's really
to increase redundancy and avoid
downtime and to ensure that
their business is highly
available and also scalable.
And we see this a lot in our
financial services customers
and also our health
care customers as well.
So as our customers are actually
embarking on this journey
to cloud, there are
multiple ways of migration.
It's not a single path to cloud.
And when we have a look at it,
when they start with legacy
on premise, there are
actually a number of options
that they can take.
They can modernize
on premise, where
they could start taking some
of those applications that
are monolith applications,
whether they're commercially
off-the-shelf
applications or something
that they've built
in-house, and start
breaking down into
smaller microservices
and taking that microservices
architecture approach.
When they do that, they also
have the ability to, then,
take those modernized
applications, microservices,
and whatnot and then
move to the cloud.
Now, not every
single application
can be broken down
into microservices.
So one of the strategies
that our customers take
is the lift and shift, where
they take existing monolith
applications and then move
it into the cloud itself.
Now, that doesn't necessarily
bring all the advantages
of cloud, naturally.
But it does reduce
operational overhead.
It does reduce the cost of
having to procure new hardware.
It does reduce the need to
keep up with upgrade cycles,
patching up the OS and whatnot.
So there are some advantages
of just doing a lift and shift.
And interestingly
enough, it's never
just one way which is more nice,
on prem and then move to cloud
or lift and shift and
then move to the cloud
and then modernize.
It's usually
somewhere in between,
where within the
same company, even
within the same
organization, they actually
do both, where they
start modernizing on prem
and also start lifting and
shifting certain workloads
into the cloud.
For folks that aren't
familiar with Apigee,
Apigee is an API
management platform
which provides the
ability for you
to create API
proxies and facades,
which sit in front of
your back-end systems,
such as cloud applications,
legacy on-premise applications,
commercially off-the-shelf
applications that
have been traditionally
deployed on premise.
Now, when we create that
facade through Apigee,
you get a number
of capabilities,
such as security,
analytics, and visibility
into who is actually now
calling into those APIs
and back-end systems.
You have the ability
to publish those APIs
to develop a portal for internal
and external consumption,
thereby creating an additional
channel for consumption
for your business.
Now, the benefit of
being able to do this
is your applications that
consume your APIs do not
need to know where those APIs
are actually implemented,
whether they're on premise,
in the cloud, application
A, application B,
or even versions
of those same
applications itself.
This is very powerful as it
helps our customers create
an ability to then plan what
they want to move and modernize
into the cloud itself.
So let's take a look
at an example of this.
Today you might start off
with an on-premise data center
where you have existing
workloads itself.
You can now leverage
Google Cloud platform
to either build new
greenfield applications
or even to even
experiment, right?
You can start with
non-production workloads
or even start looking at things
like cloud bursting, where
you use Google
Cloud to supplement
your on-premise resources.
As you get comfortable
with Google Cloud Platform,
we can then start doing
things like lift and shit,
as we saw in the
previous slides, where
we take those existing
on-premise applications
and then deploy them
onto Google Cloud itself,
using something like
Google Compute Engine.
The other strategy, which
was to modernize in place, so
breaking down existing
applications into my core
services and leveraging
things like Kubernetes
on premise, where you have now
created these microservices
which can then be
deployed into Kubernetes,
scaled automatically
through Kubernetes.
So with those
modernized microservices
that have been deployed or
developed on Kubernetes itself,
we can then easily migrate
them to Google Cloud Platform,
and more specifically into
Google Kubernetes Engine, GKE.
So at the end of the
day, all these efforts
are really for the
applications at the front end,
consuming the APIs itself.
So where we see API
management helping
is sitting between the
two infrastructures,
whether it's on premise or in
the cloud, which then provides
that facade and protects
the consumers from needing
to know specifically where they
need to consume the APIs from.
So with that, what are
some of the challenges
that our customers are
actually experiencing
when they think about
modernization and migration
to the cloud itself?
They think about business
continuity, right?
As they move applications
to the cloud,
they should not cause
any outage or disruption
to their existing customers.
And this can be
customers from internal
and could be customers from
an external point of view.
They also need to
consider security,
because data inherently
will live in multiple places
and be accessed in
multiple places as well.
You don't want to be
compromised or leave
APIs open for consumption
without any control
or visibility, which
brings us to visibility.
Without an API
management layer, it
becomes very difficult
to understand
who your consumers are, be able
to control which applications
are actually
consuming those APIs,
and understand are they
consuming them in a fashion
that you actually want them to--
and then
interoperability as well.
As you lift and shift
certain applications,
you want to maintain
applications
that are traditionally more
familiar with things like SOAP
web services and continue to be
able to offer those things up
in an easy and consumable
fashion itself.
And lastly, you want to be able
to handle unmanaged services.
Traditionally, as you build out
microservices or applications
itself, how do you actually
understand those consumptions
of those services themself?
Without some sort of
visibility, without some sort
of API management layer,
it becomes very difficult
as you scale out.
So how can Apigee help?
So in terms of service
connectivity and helping
business continuity, we can
create that abstraction layer
between GCP and also
on premise itself.
We can create an
abstraction layer
between legacy application
and modernized applications
themselves.
We hide the complexity of
the application migration
because your consumers
no longer need
to know where those new services
or legacy services live.
They can continue to consume
the way that they're used to.
With APIs management,
you now have the ability
to also enforce
security consistently
across all your APIs.
You can also use Apigee
to facilitate things
like mediation between
security protocols.
And that's something
that we'll discuss
with a particular customer use
case in a couple more minutes.
We get great visibility.
Because now our traffic is being
proxied through Apigee itself,
we capture every aspect of that
API transaction, where the API
transaction has been called
from, which application,
how often they're actually
consuming the APIs,
and what sort of
performance and error rates
they're actually seeing.
This gives you great visibility
into understanding your API
program and also
be able to improve,
extend your API program itself.
We give you API facades, where
you can modernize legacy SOAP
applications, turn them
into new RESTful APIs,
and also give you
consistency across the board.
And lastly, service management
across all your microservices
or even your traditional legacy
applications, where you now
have a single platform where
you can enforce policies
across the board, across
all those different services
and then be able to manage
it in a single pane of glass.
One of the solution
benefits in terms
of being able to
leverage Apigee,
in this particular use
case, is that you're
reducing the risk of that
migration and modernization
by creating an API facade.
You have the ability to
provide a consistent API
across the board for both
modernized services and legacy
services itself.
At the same time,
you can then start
leveraging innovative
technologies in the cloud,
so start innovating on GCP by
leveraging things like GKE, AI,
and now et cetera.
Where those services
sit shouldn't
matter to the API consumers
themselves or the applications.
Apigee will now
mediate and make sure
that it is routed to the
appropriate endpoints.
So with that, I
would like to start
talking about a specific
customer use case.
And Sarthak was
actually involved
with a particular
customer as he embarked
on this particular journey.
So with that,
Sarthak, do you want
to introduce the
actual use case itself?
SARTHAK GANGULY:
Yeah, absolutely.
So this is something I think
I worked on maybe a year or so
ago, maybe a little bit
more than that at this stage
when we started first
working on this.
So this is a retail customer
who has, as you can imagine,
a very standard legacy
on-prem data center.
And like many
other customers who
are looking at that stage, how
can they modernize their stack?
How can they be
more cloud friendly,
take care of capabilities
like cloud bursting
and horizontal scalability
and things like that?
So when we first
started talking to them,
this is how major portion
of the stack looked like.
So they had this
whole huge legacy,
on-prem, e-commerce
software, which
was a huge monolith, which
had all the capabilities
from the customer
management system
to surge to shopping
cart, everything built in.
And then there were-- as
part of the same solution,
they had a bunch of applications
like web apps, mobile apps,
and whatnot, which would
then consume those services
on the back end via APIs.
Keep in mind here, both the
front end and the back end
were part of the
same solution suite.
So this was the current
stage from where we
started our conversation from.
JOEY WONG: And what
were the challenges
the customer was facing?
And what were they
trying to solve, I guess,
from this state itself?
SARTHAK GANGULY: So I think
there were two challenges.
One was, I, think that's
the pain point which
they had for a long
time, which was
the front end and the back
end was very tightly coupled.
And so the thing was
like the front end,
they have a very different
pace of innovation.
They have a very different
technology stack.
There's a very different
mindset of the developers who
are working on an iOS
app versus someone who
is working on the shopping
carts, e-commerce system.
So there was a friction for a
long time about all of that.
The front end guys, they
were not able to work faster,
fixing bugs faster.
They did not have
enough flexibility.
And there was a constant tension
across those different teams
which had been brewing for
many, many years, right?
But I don't think that was
kind of their tipping point.
Their tipping point was
for various reasons.
A few years back, they started--
a couple of years back,
I think--
they started seriously
considering cloud.
And they wanted to go
to cloud because things
like they want to do horizontal
scalability for the peak days,
like Black Fridays and whatnot,
and not over provision capacity
for long.
So once they started
looking at that,
then this very tightly coupled
monolithic architecture
became a real
problem, that I think
that was as far as
that tipping point
that, hey, we need
to do something
about this architecture if
we have to actually embark
on this cloud journey.
JOEY WONG: So in effect, there
were two parts of it, right?
One was the agility and to
be able to innovate quickly.
And that was being--
SARTHAK GANGULY: Correct.
JOEY WONG: Because it was
based on an old architecture,
it was becoming very difficult
for the applications to do so.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Right.
JOEY WONG: And I
think the second one
that you mentioned was around
the scalability, right?
SARTHAK GANGULY: Scalability, as
well as all the other benefits
which cloud provides.
Once they wanted to
take advantage of that,
then this became a problem.
Scalability, the
horizontal scalability,
so that no more provisioning,
on-demand scalability,
all the other security
which they get in cloud,
all those things
became a problem.
JOEY WONG: So how did they
actually begin their journey?
SARTHAK GANGULY: So
one of the first things
they did was they
inserted Apigee
in between those client
and the back end.
So Apigee is a facade, as
Joey mentioned previously.
So their idea was that we
already have so those APIs.
How to decouple them?
Insert Apigee to
create this facade,
and now suddenly there is
abstraction between what
the clients are consuming,
the client applications are
consuming, and what a
back end is producing.
So now what are
they going to do is
they can change the back end.
And then inside
the Apigee layer,
they can transform the pillars,
the security protocols,
the error codes,
and all those things
to match to what the client
applications actually
are looking for.
So it becomes the flexibility of
the agility layer, if you may,
using this to decouple that
front-end applications where
the back end is huge monolith.
JOEY WONG: Awesome.
And then what other
things did Apigee provide?
Seeing as we're now proxying the
traffic between the application
and the system, was analytics
something that was important?
SARTHAK GANGULY:
Yeah, exactly, right?
So because once you
insert Apigee in
and once you start having
all those API calls,
well, the first
thing they did was
they looked at the Analytics.
As a lot of Apigee customers
do because using Analytics,
they could first--
for the first time,
they could see which one of
the services, which of the APIs
are getting called
at what frequency.
What can be considered
as a load-time downtime
to move something over?
Which APIs have the
most problem in terms
of which is taking the
most highest latency?
Which has the error
rates being higher?
All those kind of metrics.
And based on that, they decided
their whole business journey
that which of those services
can be migrated when.
And so essentially that journey
started from a deep look
at Analytics.
And it took many,
many weeks where
they created many
customer reports
and looked at many of the
standard reports, which Apigee
provides, to understand all
those aspects from error rates,
latency, traffic patterns.
How does it vary by geography?
How is it varying by
different clients,
like how is it varying by
Android versus iOS versus web.
All those things, as
they looked at it,
that's what helped them decide
how they can migrate something
to cloud.
JOEY WONG: So even
just by simply
putting Apigee as
the side layer,
as the proxy between the
API requests, the customer
was able to get deep
Analytics insight
and then use that to help
them plan their path to cloud.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Exactly.
JOEY WONG: The next
step, obviously,
was then to start breaking down
some of those capabilities.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Yeah, and
that was the whole idea, right?
So what they wanted
to do is they wanted
to refactor this monolith.
They wanted to get
out of the monolith
and take some of those
individual services
and put them in GCP, in
Google Cloud Platform.
So in this case, you
can see that they
have done that with search.
But we would say
that search is also
on prem because
in this stage, I'm
showing the scenario
when they were just
in the middle of
transitioning, right?
So they have, let's say,
refactored the whole service.
They're running that on
GCP, a brand new service.
But the latency service
is still running on prem
Now they are using Apigee to
first and foremost facilitate
almost like a
blue-green deployment,
so that they route some
traffic to GCP, some traffic
to on prem.
And then, at some
stage when they're
confident that
their cloud service,
their refactored
service is good enough,
that's when they migrate.
Or that's where they route all
those APIs calls to GCP instead
of routing them on prem.
But also you can see
the other beauty is now
they can break out an individual
service out of the monolith.
And the client applications,
they don't see the impact.
And that's the biggest benefit.
So the client
applications, the guys
who are writing, who
specialize in AngularJS
and writing those web apps, he
doesn't see all these changes
happening behind the scenes.
For him, those clients, this
is completely transparent.
Now, as they move
to GCP and they
build this thing in
Google Kubernetes
Engine, all microservices,
they are writing
new standards of the APIs.
So everything is JSON over REST
and new security standards.
And then Apigee is transforming
all of that to the legacy
or to the-- what is the
standard with the client
applications expect to see?
So that's the biggest advantage
that as you start moving,
Apigee acts as a blue-green
deployment, a facilitator,
if you may.
And then it provides
all that flexibility
and to basically bring
together the legacy interface
and the modern
interface together.
JOEY WONG: Awesome.
So as they progress,
they would then
start deprecating certain things
on premise so by removing,
say, search from
their on premise
and then start looking, again,
using things like Analytics
to understand what would
be a good candidate
to move into cloud?
SARTHAK GANGULY: Yeah, exactly.
And I mean, now,
in this case, we
can see that in
this scenario, they
had couple of
services in the Cloud
and some services on prem.
But the front-end
applications, they
don't see all that movement
happening behind the scenes.
And the beauty is
what we actually
saw-- since now the
front-end developers,
they had more flexibility,
instead of actually slowing
down, they can
actually went ahead
and they created new
apps on the front end.
Because now they know that,
oh, this is my API definition,
and this is the API
definition against which
I'm building everything.
And this API
definition is not going
to change every time some small
thing changes on the back-end.
Previously, that
was a big challenge.
If they do an upgrade
of any of the services,
or of that e-commerce
platform, or they did anything,
there was a big probability that
the front-end apps will break.
And that's where the front-end
developers spent a lot of time
to make sure when all the
back-end things changes,
their things did not break.
JOEY WONG: So by creating
an API-first strategy, that
gave the customer an ability
to innovate and create new APIs
and services and then be able
to implement them using whatever
technology they choose to.
SARTHAK GANGULY:
And in new apps.
I mean, they were kind of stuck
at having those Android and iOS
apps at a pretty legacy
technology for a while
because they just did not have
time other than firefighting,
other than to comply
with the back end
because it is the same engine,
at the end of the day, which
is supporting their
stores as well
as their e-commerce engine.
So there were requirements
from all sides, which
will shape that back end,
which the front-end guys had
no control on.
They were always with
their reactionary mode
so that left their mobile
apps and their web apps
in a pretty dire state.
It was pretty legacy technology.
They did not have
native Android app.
And there were a
need for a couple
of other modern applications,
like for their B2B scenarios
and things like that.
So finally, while all this
back-end mayhem, if you may,
is going on, that's
when they were
able to roll up their sleeves
and build some new applications
and improve and modernize
their existing applications.
JOEY WONG: Awesome.
And then, inherently, a
question that always comes up
is by introducing
another layer is--
what sort of performance
challenges, or if any,
were faced?
SARTHAK GANGULY: Are you
talking in terms of latency?
JOEY WONG: Yeah, latency.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Yeah, so I
don't think we showed here.
But as you can imagine,
with the retail,
there are a lot of
services, like catalogs,
and customer data, and--
JOEY WONG: Store locations.
SARTHAK GANGULY: --store
location, and all of that data.
All those things are cacheable.
And Apigee has a very powerful
caching layer with level one
and level two cache built in.
Wherever that was possible, they
actually used the Apigee cache,
and that actually reduced their
latency quite drastically.
Now, in some other cases,
which cannot be cached,
which are real
time, for example,
like your shopping cart or,
let's say, recommendation,
because recommendations
constantly change,
those things, whether
there was a latency add--
yeah, maybe.
But keep in mind,
in those cases,
we're looking at
APIs which are taking
a few seconds from the
app to the back end
to do all the stuff and go back.
And then Apigee's
latency add was,
like, single digit in
milliseconds or double-digit
milliseconds, so like 20, 30
milliseconds-- in that range.
And given the amount of
benefits, which we are getting,
a 30-millisecond bump
compared to a three second
was not considered much.
And obviously,
there are a huge set
of APIs, huge set of
services for which there
was a huge, huge
performance bump wherever
they could use the caching
policy, which is built in.
One other thing I might add
is although it might not
look obvious, as you are
going through the journey,
we started off with a
lot of heavy APIs, which
were SOAP, which were XMLA.
As we are going
through the journey,
the APIs were a lot lighter.
They were JSON over REST.
We are liking lightweight
microservices.
So as part of the
overall journey,
the [INAUDIBLE] or the
latency of the APIs--
JOEY WONG: Actually
became better.
SARTHAK GANGULY:
--became a lot better
than what it was previously.
JOEY WONG: Awesome.
And then I can imagine as
well with the caching, that's
an interesting use case because
now, if you're returning
a response from the cache
closer to the application that's
consuming the APIs,
you could potentially
be servicing more transactions
because you're not necessarily
hitting the back-end system.
SARTHAK GANGULY: So yeah,
that's actually a great point.
So one of the challenges
they had was--
so the back end, when the
e-commerce engine was built
and that whole
infrastructure was built,
that was built
thinking of the world
with a browser-first
approach, web word.
Which was like, oh, this
can have, let's say,
whatever, x number of
calls simultaneously,
10x number of calls
a day or whatnot.
They did not think inherently
the mobile-first approach
and the scale which
mobile brings in.
And they had severe
problems with lot
of outages at various different
times, slow performance,
and things like that,
especially during peak hours.
They had all of that.
So as they were able
to cache in Apigee
using the L1 and L2 layer,
a lot of those performance
worries, at least for some of
those services like shopping--
sorry, like product
catalogs and all, those
were drastically reduced.
JOEY WONG: Yeah, I can
imagine in today's world even
with Google Assistant,
at Google Homes, yeah,
that's another avenue, another
channel that's flowing up.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Exactly.
No one thought of those
avenues five years back.
JOEY WONG: Yeah.
So in this particular
diagram in the final state,
there's an interesting thing
here where you actually--
the customer's actually
operating in both Google Cloud
and in their own
traditional data center.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Correct.
JOEY WONG: Can you share
with us some of the--
SARTHAK GANGULY: Yeah, so
what happened is, at the end
of the day, they decided that
they will migrat and rewrite
and whatnot most of the
applications in cloud,
but they were not going
to rewrite shopping cart.
Shopping cart, they are going
to maintain in the existing
e-commerce solution on
prem because it is a very
complex piece of software.
And they did not see any
business value by rewriting it.
So as they were migrating-- and
we talked about in the previous
slides--
Apigee was the layer
behind which they migrated.
But not only that,
Apigee was the layer
which created the hybrid
and the final state, when--
so their final steady state
will be they have their shopping
cart application
on prem and they
have all the other
applications as microservices
and whatnot in GCP.
And then Apigee sits in front,
which then routes traffic
to either GCP or to shopping
cart based on different logics
put inside Apigee.
So this is actually
Apigee helping
in creating a hybrid state,
built in on prem and Cloud,
using an API-first approach.
So normally when
you think of hybrid,
customers start thinking in
terms of, oh, I need to do--
I need to set up a VPN.
I need to set up a VPC.
I need to set up an interconnect
and all of those kind of things
to do hybrid.
Yes, that would be
true in some scenarios.
In other scenarios, if you
do an API-first paradigm,
if you do an API-first
design for applications,
you can do it at a
hybrid like this.
And this is
something we actually
see customers do quite often,
not only just in one scenario.
We have many, many
customers who are
doing this kind of
hybrid deployments.
JOEY WONG: That's
an amazing story.
I believe this was actually
done in a quite a short period
of time as well.
SARTHAK GANGULY: Yeah,
I mean the overall--
I honestly don't have the
whole time frame in mind.
But the initial thing--
the initial proof of concept,
the initial first migration
of the application and
whatnot was achieved
within just a few months.
Now, as you can imagine, there
are all these different pieces.
That needs to moved.
That needs to be rewritten,
and tested, and run.
So that's a--
I mean, I wouldn't
trivialize it.
That's a pretty decent project.
But to proof out this
concept and to see
if we can take away one service
out and rewrite it, run it
on Google Kubernetes
Engine, plug that to Apigee,
and then expose a set of
APIs, a coherent set of APIs
to all the client
applications, that
was done in actually a
very short period of time,
in like a couple of months.
I think it's like a
little more than a month.
And that actually
amazed our customer.
They did not expect--
JOEY WONG: Yeah, I mean, not
meaning to trivialize it,
but I'm just--
I guess the question is,
how much longer would it
have taken?
How much more complex
would it have been?
SARTHAK GANGULY: I
mean, they didn't
do this for so many years.
I mean, they had
this e-commerce,
this on-prem monolith
application for so many years.
They couldn't do it.
I mean, it's not
that they just--
it was the first time they
thought about doing this.
They have thinking about
doing this for a while
because they had all these
challenges for a while.
So I mean, without having
this layer as Apigee, Apigee
at that layer, they
couldn't even achieve that.
JOEY WONG: They
couldn't achieve it.
They couldn't even think
about taking that task.
SARTHAK GANGULY:
How to do it, yeah.
JOEY WONG: Amazing, all right.
Thank you for
sharing that with us.
SARTHAK GANGULY:
Yeah, absolutely.
JOEY WONG: So with that, we're
going to actually bring it
up to a Q&A session now.
So if there's any questions,
please feel free to speak up
or type it into the chat
channel, and let's open it up.
Thank you.
SARTHAK GANGULY:
Absolutely, thank you.
JOEY WONG: All
right, so we're just
going to wait a couple more
minutes as the questions come
flowing through.
I can already see a couple--
everybody come through.
So just give me a minute.
OK, so we have a question here.
In this particular
case, is Apigee
running on GCP or on premise
for this particular customer?
In this one, it was
actually running on GCP,
and we are managing
it as a service
for our customer itself.
Naturally, Apigee is also
available as on premise
deployment so that
you can actually
choose to deploy it into
your own data center
or into your own
private cloud as well.
We have another question.
How do you see and
suggest to users of Apigee
in a multi-cloud environment?
So I'm going to
try and interpret
this one a little bit.
So I guess the question is,
how would you deploy Apigee
in a multi-cloud environment?
Again, you can either choose
to use Apigee as a service
where Apigee Google
would actually then
provision you an
instance, and then we
would then manage and operate
that instance for you.
Now, you also have the
ability to then also choose
to use the on premise deployment
to deploy into your own data
center or into your
own private cloud
and then have that
manage your API calls
and mediate and broker
it between the two
environments or multiple
environments itself.
The questions are
flowing in very fast,
so hopefully I can get
through a lot of it.
So will this be
available post-event?
Yes, it will be.
We will follow up with some
emails around that itself.
So we do have some
repeat questions.
So another one here is
where is the API manager
sitting when we use
Cloud and on premise?
I believe that's been answered.
In this particular
case, we are hosting
the API platform itself.
So we have another
question here.
And the question here
is, customer database
seems to be a common hybrid
component but complicated
with firewall issues
in data residency.
How have you solved for this?
So it's a number of factors.
So some of those things
might be an issue
with moving to the Cloud.
So they might actually
have to sit on premise.
So if you recall back into the
actual presentation itself,
our customer actually left
one of their components
in the data center, which
was a shopping cart, which
is actually handling the credit
card payments themselves.
Now, with customer
database, that
can also be the same
case where the database
itself would need
to live on premise.
But you would expose out
an API that we would then
manage as part of the API
management platform in Apigee
to then provide security
and control over who uses
that particular API itself.
We have another question here.
How do you secure the connection
between on-premise application
and Apigee?
So if you're using our
managed services itself,
we have two options,
and some customers
choose to use one or the other,
or some customers use both.
And typically, what
they do is they
use IP whitelisting where we
can provide you a range of IPs.
And they also use neutral TLS
where the certificates are
provisioned to ensure that
only Apigee gateways could talk
to your data centers itself.
We have another question.
For Google Cloud, does Apigee
provide adaptive hooking
into Google Kubernetes Engine?
So I don't believe we have
specific adapters for GKE
today.
But we have actually
something called Extensions,
which has now started
being leveraged to connect
to GCP services.
So things like
Pub/Sub, BigQuery, AIML
are becoming extensions
that are becoming available.
And as we create more of these
extensions and connectors,
our cloud customers
can then leverage
to further integrate with
and extend their applications
using GCP.
OK, we do have another question.
Can we do monetization
using Apigee?
Yes, we can.
Monetization is a module that
sits as part of the platform.
So we do have customers that are
leveraging monetization today
to be able to open up a
new digital revenue channel
and then leverage
that capability itself
to do things like
reporting all the way up
to actually charging the
customers that actually
want to leverage their APIs.
Can you talk about
internal usage
of Apigee between internal
applications and/or services?
Great question.
So internal usage and
external usage are different.
But at the same
time, it is actually
quite similar in that
developers, whether they're
internal or external,
want to have similar sort
of experiences between--
in actually accessing API.
So if you have a look at what's
available out in the market
today, there's always
a developer.company.com
where APIs are
published for people
to discover and understand
and subsequently
also be able to test with
those APIs immediately.
They also want to be able to
do things like self-service
where they can request
full access to the APIs
and have it
automatically generate
you a API key for, say, a
sandbox environment itself.
Is there an Apigee
certification program?
Absolutely.
So we offer courses on Coursera,
and that also gives you
a level of certification.
We do have a more extensive
certification program.
Feel free to reach out
to Apigee to find out
more details about it.
Do we have documentation
on this kind of setup?
If you head over to
our Documentation page,
we do have the
on-premise documentation,
which talks about setting
up Apigee on premise.
In this particular case, it
was a cloud-managed service.
And it becomes more
of a configuration
rather than in a
complete set up itself.
Do we have integration
with Kubernetes and Istio?
Great question.
So for folks that
don't know, Kubernetes
is an orchestration engine.
And recently, there
was a new project
that has come out called Istio.
Istio is what we call a
service mesh tool, which
helps you manage your
microservices within something
like the Kubernetes
infrastructure.
Now, Apigee itself has
a integration with Istio
where, as you can
imagine, you have
tons of these microservices
within your Kubernetes
infrastructure.
But you also want to
be able to then manage
some of these services as APIs.
So as part of the Istio
expansion capabilities,
we have built an adaptor
between Istio and Apigee
where you can take some
of those microservices
and actually manage them
through the management
platform within Apigee itself.
For more details, just do a--
go to our Apigee
Documentation site.
And there is an Istio section
specific to that as well.
How to monetize products?
So Apigee is a complete
API management platform,
and as part of that, we do
have a monetization module.
So you can actually create what
we call different rate plans
against different API products.
These products can
then be something
that you make publicly
available or you push
towards specific consumers.
They can be defined
as simple as a bucket
where a consumer would need
to pay a monthly charge.
Or you can come up with
more exotic sort of plans
where perhaps it's tiered,
where the first tier
they would pay x amount.
And then once they exceeded
an amount of calls,
they would then be
charged less or more,
depending on what type of
model that you're trying to do.
The question, is this specific
to just retail organizations
or is this something you are
seeing across all industries
and verticals?
That is a great question,
and it is across all
industries and verticals.
Retail is something that
we see a lot happening.
But naturally, across
financial and health services
as well, they are
getting more and more
comfortable with cloud.
And therefore, they're
actually starting
to leverage Apigee
as the platform
to help them move and
modernize into the cloud.
And before-- just something else
I was told to actually push--
I kind of forgot--
is as part of
today's webcast, we
are actually selecting
three webcast attendees
and actually giving
them NEXT passes.
So NEXT is Google Cloud's
annual three-day conference.
It's going to be hosted
in San Francisco, which
takes place on April the
9th to the 11th this year.
So our team itself
will be contacting
three of our lucky
winners by early next week
and giving them the passes.
So keep an eye out on
your emails itself.
How does this help in
traffic management?
So Apigee, as a complete
API management platform,
has a number of policies
that actually help you
with traffic management.
So things like
quota are available
and also where you can
actually define things
like x number of calls per
month, per day, per minute.
It's up to you what
you want to define.
We also do have things like
SpikeArrest, which helps
you smooth out your traffic.
So think of it as
a way to prevent
DDoS calls into your platform.
We also have things that can
actually improve performance.
So things like caching
are available as part
of the policies to
actually allow you
to define what your keys are.
And then if a request comes
in with the same request,
same key, Apigee itself can
serve the traffic out into--
back into the API
consumer itself,
thereby avoiding having
to go all the way
back up to the back-end
system to retrieve.
Do you normally need a
service mesh like Istio
if your microservices
are on PCF?
No.
So Istio is a new way of
managing microservices
in a mesh.
We have a ton of customers
that have built microservices
on PCF.
And actually, PCF, or
Pivotal, is a partner of ours.
And we have built integrations
between our platforms
to ensure that, as
you're building out
microservices and
deploying them onto PCF,
you can also leverage Apigee
to provision what we call
a microgateway or even use their
full-blown edge proxy to secure
those microservices itself.
Check out our Documentation
page for more details.
All right, so we do
have a question here.
Do we have Qwiklabs to try
out some concepts and labs
on Istio, GKE, and more?
We actually run these
API Jams quite often.
So keep your eye out
on the Events page
for the next API Jam, which also
can include these components as
well.
From there, you can actually
play with it for free.
Can Apigee help in
versioning off the API?
Absolutely.
So there are different
ways of versioning APIs.
The one that we see
most common is actually
through putting the V1 or V2 in
the URL, or URI, I should say.
And that gives you
the ability to,
again, deploy multiple versions
of the same API as well.
Internally, within
Apigee, you also
have the ability to
leverage something
called Revisions,
where we keep a copy
of your previous
deployment of an API proxy,
which gives you an ability
to then roll forward or roll
backwards as you need.
What is the adoption rate for
Istio with Apigee as of today?
Do you have customers
moving to a service mesh?
So we certainly have customers
that are leveraging things
like Kubernetes.
And then naturally, they're
looking at Istio as well.
There are a smaller
subset of our customers
that are using
Istio in production.
But they are somewhat more
limited because at the rate--
at the current stage,
Istio is fairly new.
But what every one
of our customers
are doing, especially if
they're Kubernetes adopters,
is they're actually now
experimenting and making sure
that they are keeping
in sync with what's
happening with Istio,
what's happening
with Istio and Apigee, and
service meshes in general.
I think we are going
to be coming up
to the end of this
session itself.
So with that, I would
like to thank you all
for attending today's event.
We will answer your questions
in the chat channel.
But let me just promote
our next event itself.
So we run these
events bi-monthly.
So our next event is going
to be around understanding
how developers are
today kingmakers.
And we have
[INAUDIBLE] from Apigee
who will be delivering the
session on how this trend is
not only growing but
how to actually create
an ecosystem around
your developers
with an API-centric mindset,
thereby encouraging more
and more of your developers
to actually leverage
the power of APIs itself.
And then lastly, if you are
not a current Apigee customer,
or if you're just exploring
the market itself,
please feel free
to actually sign up
for a free trial
on our platform.
We offer a ton of documentation.
We offer a ton of our
videos as well on YouTube
for you to be able to
understand how you can actually
leverage Apigee to manage
your API program itself.
And then with that, thank you
very much, and have a good day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]